I'm sure she will carry out the
Chairman's role very properly and in
that sense you're very much led by the
other members of committee and what they
want to discuss in the areas that are of
interest to them rather than it being
something where the Chairman just plows
ahead with whatever his or her views are
yes I imagine Malkani we quite relieved
that you didn't get the chairmanship to
ask him now all we see we've got the
great repeal bill going through today
it's going to be very very difficult um
it's gonna be hand-to-hand combat all
the way through and getting this bill
through isn't it um I think it will be
similar to what happened over Maastricht
that the Labour Party accepts the bill
in principle that we are leaving the
European Union but will use its role as
the opposition party to oppose that's
what opposition parties do and to make
the passage of the bill
contentious there is however one very
important thing to bear in mind and that
is that since article 50 was passed into
law and since the notification was given
we are leaving the European Union by the
end of March 2019 if this bill is not
passed then the European law that is in
UK law has no basis it doesn't rest on
anything and therefore we would have a
vacuum in our law and potentially a very
chaotic situation but what about some of
these issues on which there are clearly
members of your own party uneasy your
Atem for example are you going to have
to accept that the ECJ still will have
some influence over British policy I
mean by some influence under the 1972
European communities act and as a member
of the European Union ecj judgments are
the highest law in the land they
overturn UK law that cannot continue
after brexit that our laws must be made
in Parliament and can the ECJ act as a
tribunal in the way that the WTO has a
tribunal and the European Court of Human
Rights Act as a tribunal which may then
be accepted into British law but can be
refused that's an entirely separate
question what have you made of the
offers being made
by Emmanuel macron to French nationals
and indeed to london-based banks to
relocate to Paris um and they are
rolling out the red carpet they're
offering to cut taxes cut regulations
this is an excellent and that I believe
in competition and that if the French
start competing for business then the
British must compete back and we must
look at whether we've got the right tax
incentive for business the right levels
of regulation for business and ensure
that we can compete and keep business
here I'm in favor of competition which
tends to improve the environment for
everybody I made the comment
interestingly just now that banks need
to have their own contingency plans in
place what appears to have unsettled
them this week though is Boris Johnson's
admission that there are no contingency
plans on the part of government for a
so-called harbor exit the terminology is
deliberately confusing soft brexit means
remaining within the European Union
means rejecting what voters said on the
23rd of June 2016 and it's just a code
word that they used because they don't
want to admit that they're trying to
punish the electorate so we need to bear
that in mind if we leave without a deal
the great news is we don't have to give
the European Union any money at all as
it's clearly been established in EU UK
and international law by an excellent
report by our House of Lords committee
so that's the first thing we keep all
our money if we leave without a deal and
we then trade on WTO terms which is how
we do about 60% of our global trade
currently so it's a really strong
position it's maintaining other
international agreements it's not that
there is a complete vacuum it's that we
just fall back on older arrangements
that we use with other countries was it
very helpful of Boris Johnson to say
that the you could go whistle it was
brilliant I hope that they are
whistling busily and making a jolly and
joyful tune because we need more
optimism in this debate leaving the EU
is a fantastic opportunity of the United
Kingdom and potentially for the EU as
well so whistling a jolly tune whistle
while you work that would be my advice
to all in
satyrs